[Music]
so
back to what i was saying before
my theory oh god um steve rogers did not
have a girlfriend before he went into
the service
says who
the history channel so he becomes
captain america and from that moment on
a symbol of america he is rushed to the
front lines he becomes a war hero then
he is frozen in ice right so based on
everything you've told me
after he gets unfrozen he goes from
world threatening disaster to
world-threatening disaster that's when
he's not a fugitive from the law right
so it seems like he was pretty pretty
busy all you're doing is repeating
everything that i've already told you
about my friend and colleague obviously
captain america was a virgin
[Music]
wow jesus what the hell man feeling
controlling the overwhelming feelings of
rage no a normal amount of rage you do
revert back to gen 4 when you sleep was
the air horn really necessary for comedy
absolutely
this is a multi-year journey you're
about to embark on
yeah who's your best friend nikki
spandex spandex is your best friend
being a hulk asks for balance
you have so much more to learn
yes
so i'm clearly nailing it at all these
things
if you want to go back to life as a
lawyer i i respect that
he doesn't mean that
more and more eccentric superhumans are
coming out of the woodwork
we are going to launch a division for
them and i want the she-hulk to be the
face of
jennifer wallace
namaste
i have a serious conflict of interest
this man tried to kill my cousin bruce
yeah that's quite all right oh
people only care because i'm
representing emil bonski i think they
care cause they're like hey that girl's
green
jen do your thing god i really like this
outfit
i'm not proud of this
miss walters we answered to a higher
power our universe is on the edge of a
precipice
i am a lawyer
we do things by the book
the book of the shanty no the book of
american
uh loss
whether you like it or not you're now a
superhero
let's do this
you know that friend you had in high
school
who was way cooler than you were
attractive got all the attention from
everyone
hello
i think i'm jealous is that what i'm
feeling
[Music]
[Music]
you